i
[Música]
a
los ministros de la suprema corte de
justicia fijaron un plazo al congreso
mexicano para legislar sobre el uso
recreativo de la marihuana este plazo
vence el próximo 30 de abril y la ley
sigue atorada en el congreso y es que
los senadores diseñaron un conjunto de
normas para regular todas las etapas de
la cannabis desde la siembra y cultivo
hasta la producción distribución
comercialización y consumo de la misma
sin embargo los diputados le hicieron
modificaciones a la minuta que los
senadores consideran que va en contra la
constitución o rompen algunas leyes
cuáles son estos cambios por ejemplo los
diputados eliminaron la prohibición de
vender cantidades superiores a los 28
gramos de marihuana eliminaron también
la obligación de solicitar
consentimiento a terceras personas para
fumar marihuana delante de ellas por
poner algunos ejemplos los senadores
analizan la posibilidad de solicitar una
nueva prórroga a la corte para diseñar
una ley que no vaya en contra la
constitución pero sobre todo que cumpla
con el mandato de la corte de garantizar
el libre desarrollo de la personalidad
[Música]
en nueva york desde el 31 de marzo la
marihuana recreativa es legal esto que
significa bien pues que la planta ha
sido legalizada de manera inmediata
cualquier persona mayor de 21 años puede
cargar hasta 3 onzas de cannabis para
uso recreativo a lo que habrá que
esperar es a la venta de esta marihuana
recreativa por lo menos habrá que
esperar dos años el estado todavía tiene
que crear una agencia reguladora que
establezca las reglas para la venta de
esta marihuana recreativa también ha
habido cambios en la marihuana medicinal
que sí que estaba aprobada aquí en el
estado de nueva york pero se amplían las
condiciones médicas para acceder a ella
además todas aquellas personas que
tuvieran condenas previas por el uso
consumo de marihuana podrán ver borrados
de sus registros estas condenas previas
nueva york se une a esos 15 estados en
este país que de momento permiten el uso
de la marihuana recreativa de manera
legal
[Música]
en sudáfrica y el uso personal de la
marihuana es legal desde septiembre de
2018 aquí en el país se pueden tener
hasta 600 gramos de marihuana por
persona y hasta un límite de 1.2
kilogramos por hogar el número ilimitado
de semillas también es posible y también
es legal el regalar o donar semillas o
hasta 100 gramos de marihuana a amigos o
conocidos pero no es legal de ninguna
manera que haya una transacción
monetaria es decir está ilegalizada la
venta del producto aquí en el sur de
áfrica también es muy interesante el
caso de lesotho es un país que ha tenido
unas regulaciones muy abiertas con
respecto al uso del cannabis desde 2008
y en esta semana se ha convertido en el
primer país africano que tiene una
autorización para exportar a países de
la unión europea el ingrediente activo
de la marihuana para fines medicinales
[Música]